Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Una vez unos chicos
de secundaria me dijeron:
“Si vemos uno de gorrita,
nos cruzamos de vereda”.
En otra ocasión escuché
que una señora dijo:
“Yo solo me ocupo de mi marido
y de mis hijos”.
Y un alumno, uno de los de gorrita,
me dijo un día:
“Si es cheto, seguro que cagó a alguien
para tener lo que tiene”.
¿Cómo podemos aprender a convivir
si somos, actuamos
o pensamos tan distinto?
¿Cómo podemos encontrarnos
y concertar en la diversidad?
¿Podemos entender que somos responsables
de construir la sociedad que queremos?
Hoy quiero contarles nuestra propuesta
que desarrollamos hace 20 años
y que llamamos Orquesta-Escuela.
Porque sí, hacemos orquestas, pero las
cultivamos como una escuela de vida.
Esta propuesta la vivimos hoy niños,
jóvenes y adultos de toda la Argentina.
Pero es una metodología que aplicamos
por primera vez en Chascomús,
una hermosa ciudad de la Provincia
de Buenos Aires que, incluso por esto,
fue declarada capital nacional de
las orquestas infantiles y juveniles.
Trabajamos desde
tres dimensiones a la vez:
la individual, la familiar
y la comunitaria.
Nosotros las integramos
para hacer música juntos.
Pero es un modo de vivir que sirve
para la escuela, el ámbito laboral,
el club, los amigos, el barrio.
Para que vean de qué se trata,
vamos a armar una orquesta ahora mismo.
Lo primero es que los chicos estén.
Y para eso hay que ir a buscarlos.
Nadie puede amar lo que no conoce.
Por eso hay personas que
no pueden saber qué quieren.
Les voy a presentar a Jade,
una de mis primeras alumnas,
y ya maravillosa
profesora multiplicadora,
que va a hacer la tarea
que hacemos todos los días:
Enamorar de la propuesta Orquesta-Escuela
a personas que nunca se imaginaron
estudiando estos instrumentos.
Bienvenida Jade.
(Aplausos)
¡Qué sorpresa! Jade va a ir a buscar
a dos miembros del público
que van a ser participantes, integrantes,
de nuestra Orquesta-Escuela
del Teatro Colón.
Muchas veces para incluir no alcanza
con abrir las puertas
para que vengan, ni con que sea gratis.
Por eso nosotros vamos
a buscarlos en nuestro auto
que se fue destartalando
o en lo que podemos
pero siempre llenos de instrumentos
a sociedades de fomento,
comedores, hogares, a las plazas,
y a distintas escuelas,
conformando el 80 % de nuestro cupo
con diferentes sectores.
También, cuando creamos
una orquesta-escuela,
ofrecemos una inscripción abierta
para cubrir el 20 % del cupo restante
con niños y familias que eligen hoy
la educación musical.
Así buscamos una verdadera
integración social.
¿Quién se anima a inscribirse
para formar parte
de esta orquesta-escuela del
Teatro Colón de Buenos Aires?
Levanten la mano.
¡Cuántos valientes!
¿A ver?
Señorita,
bienvenida.
Ahora sí.
Jadita, ¿vos le explicás?
Lo que está sucediendo ahora entre Jade
y nuestros tres chelistas nuevos
es la clase personalizada.
En este espacio trabajamos
la dimensión individual.
Y la clave es la mirada.
Miramos a cada persona
como un individuo único,
con muchísimos talentos para cultivar.
Este momento es revelador.
Es donde creemos tanto,
tanto en nuestros alumnos
para que ellos crean en sí mismos.
Eso sí, los garantes del proceso
y del resultado,
somos nosotros los adultos responsables.
Nuestro desafío como docentes es ver
cómo acompañamos a cada persona;
la famosa equidad.
Para eso, a veces
el 99 % de nuestro trabajo
es antes de llegar al atril,
antes de poder iniciar un proceso.
O esto simplemente se refleja
en la elección de una obra musical
que tenga que ver con afinidades,
con talentos.
Pero todo, por supuesto,
nos tiene que permitir trabajar
lo que buscamos que aprendan
para su desarrollo personal y colectivo.
En la clase personalizada
algunos de nuestros alumnos
tienen quizá por primera vez la mirada
de un adulto para buscar su voz,
encontrarla, cuidarla, y disfrutarla,
como un tesoro propio
y como un tesoro para compartir.
Como me dijo un día una alumna,
“mi música es algo
que nadie me puede sacar”.
Porque si no encontramos
nuestra propia voz,
si no nos conocemos a nosotros mismos,
es muy difícil que podamos
estar bien con los demás.
Cuando vienen a la orquesta,
los chicos se integran
a una familia de instrumentos.
Ahí aprenden a construir experiencias
con un grupo de pertenencia.
Vamos a conformar la familia
de los violonchelos.
Bienvenidos los violonchelos.
Hola Felipe, Alina,
(Aplausos) Nataly,
(Aplausos) Agustina, y Jorgelina,
(Aplausos)
conocieron a sus amigos.
Miren que hermosa familia de violonchelos.
Para trabajar la dimensión familiar
la segunda clase,
la otra clase que proponemos
desde la orquesta-escuela
Es donde crecen juntos
los violines, la percusión,
o los violonchelos, como en este caso.
La familia de instrumentos es el primer
espacio de encuentro entre pares.
Es donde aprendemos
esos saberes transversales
que tanto nos exigen
los tiempos de hoy y de mañana,
como el trabajo en equipo.
Es donde fortalecemos nuestra identidad.
Es donde mi voz interactúa y se integra
con otras voces distintas a la mía.
Pero con lo común a otros en este
espacio construimos nuestra voz.
¿Qué nos falta?
Aprender a vivir en comunidad
uniendo nuestra voz personal
a la de nuestra familia
en un todo más amplio que nos desafía
a desarrollarnos con otros
distintos a nosotros.
Entonces, una orquesta puede convertirse
en un lugar de promoción
donde aprendamos a ser la mejor
versión de nosotros mismos
siendo parte de una comunidad diversa.
Para nosotros la excelencia
es una búsqueda.
Una búsqueda que merece hacerse
en el presente de cada uno y de todos.
Esta metodología, además,
permite que los chicos
sean parte importante de la orquesta
desde el primer momento.
Por eso, nuestras obras musicales están
intervenidas para que sean multinivel.
Esto es, que puedan ser parte
de una misma orquesta
chicos que por primera vez
tienen un chelo en las manos
junto a otros de un nivel
técnico superior.
Lo importante es que están
construyendo juntos
participando colaborativamente
como nos demostraron los chicos.
(Música de chelos)
(Aplausos)
Hoy, solo en Chascomús,
más de 7000 chicos
ya fueron parte de la orquesta.
Chicos que soñaron y hoy desarrollan
sus proyectos de vida;
que formaron hermosas familias
y hoy, como padres, traen a sus hijos.
Algunos son músicos profesionales.
Otros, además, son maravillosos
profesores multiplicadores.
Y ya no somos solo una orquesta
sino una red de orquestas en todo el país,
donde aprendemos a convivir en armonía.
Disfrutamos de nuestra diversidad,
de nuestro mundo diverso.
Y donde todos, todos, sabemos
que es mucho más divertido
que si sonamos todos iguales.
(Himno a la alegría)
(Fin Himno a la alegría)
(Aplausos)